In the last video, we saw that
China had increased its M1
money supply from November
of 2009 to November of 2010
by roughly $700 billion.
What I want to do in
this videos compare that
to it's increase
in foreign assets.
So if we move up here, and
once again, all of this data
is straight from the website
of the Peoples Bank of China.
And this is the URL
right over here.
And so you could get
it for multiple years.
and actually they have a
ton of other statistics.
And so this chart tells
us their foreign assets
and foreign exchange.
And I'm actually going to
focus on foreign assets,
because when they
print currency,
and that's to say with
their printed Yuan
they go buy dollars.
With that dollar they
could buy-- well,
they could keep it in dollars.
They could buy treasury bonds.
Or they could just
go buy US assets.
So assets are the best
measure of what they're
holding that is denominated
in other currencies.
So let's look at their
growth from November of 2009
to November of 2010.
And this is why I
picked November,
because we didn't have
December of 2010 in this chart.
So foreign assets,
and once again,
this is in hundred million Yuan.
Foreign assets in November,
2009 183,651, and that's
in 100 million Yuan.
And then you fast forward to
November, 2010 it is 212,733.
So let's, once again,
put that in terms
that make a little bit
more sense, at least
for someone who's
used to dollars.
And I used a very
rough approximation
for the US Yuan exchange
rate in the last video.
It's actually
closer to 6.58 now.
But it gets us to about
$700 billion increase
in money supply that we
got in the last video.
Now, let's check this out.
So we end up at 212,733
hundred million Yuan
in foreign assets, November,
2010 minus 183,651.
So that's the difference.
Now this is in
hundred million Yuan.
So let's multiply by 100.
And so this will
be in million Yuan.
Now if we divide this by 1,000
this will give us billion Yuan.
So it's actually close to--
its 2,900 billion Yuan.
So it's almost
three trillion Yuan.
And if we want to convert
this into dollars--
I'll just use the same 6.5.
I could use 6.58.
Oh, let me just do 6.58.
So divided by 6.58, to put it
into billions of US dollars.
So you see that there
is a $440 billion
increase in foreign assets
when denominated in dollars.
So let's think about that.
So let's think about this.
M1, so from November,
2009 to November, 2010 M1
was up by approximately
$700 billion.
And the foreign assets
were up by approximately,
what was that number
that I just had there?
Approximately $440 billion.
So most of the expansion
of their monetary base,
of their M1 base, was to go
out and buy foreign assets
over the course of 2010.
And the balance is really
just to kind of support
the growth of the
actual Chinese economy.
But most of it is to go out
there, buy foreign assets
in other currencies,
and actually help
keep the Yuan devalued.
This is Salman Khan of
the Khan Academy for CNBC.